Y
HALLOWEEN, EVERYBODY.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE B/R
BETTING SQUAD RIDE LIVE IN THE
BLOECHER REPORT APP.
I'M CONNOR ROGERS ALONGSIDE THE
HOODIE KING, THE GUY THAW WANT
TO STOP BY HIS HOUSE TO NOT GET
CANDY, BUT ALL THE GOOD
GIVEAWAYS, NFL JERSEYS, TONS OF
HOODIES.
GREG, HOW WE FEELING TODAY?
>> FEELING GOOD.
FEELING GENEROUS.
IN FACT, CONNOR, I FEEL LIKE
GIVING OUT A HOODIE NOW.
WHY NOT?
I AM IN THE HANDY DANDY iPAD FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT'S NEW TO THE
SHOW.
THIS IS THE DEVICE THAT YOU GET
YOUR HOODIES ON.
>> THIS IS THE DEVICE THAT I SEE
YOUR TAKES.
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
FILL UP THOSE COMMENTS WITH GOOD
TAKES AND I AM GETTING AWAY
HOODIES LIKE Z ROD 04, HE SIMPLY
COMMENTED ZACK MOSS.
GUESS WHAT, CONNOR?
ZACH
MOSS IS ON MY FANTASY TEAM.
THEREFORE, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
SIMPLE AS THAT.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE, CONNOR.
>> THIS IS A SHOW WE BET ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORES.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHO IS GETTING
IN THE END ZONE.
HERE IS THE MOST POPULAR PICKS.
DERRICK HENRY DID NOT SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN RUNNING OR RECEIVING
LAST WEEK.
USUALLY IS A GOOD SIGN FOR THIS
WEEKEND.
ALVIN KAMARA AND JOE MIXON, OF
COURSE, TWO OTHER RUNNING BACKS
AT THE TOP.
STEFON DIGGS AND JOSH AL ALLEN A
NICE CONNECTION FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
JA'MARR CHASE THE UNDISPUTED
FUTURE ROOKIE OF THE YEAR.
MIKE WILLIAMS, HOPEFULLY, THAT
BYE WEEK GAVE HIS KNEE TIME TO
HEAL UP AND GET RIGHT AND BE THE
DOMINANT HE HAS BEEN EARLY IN
THE SEASON.
AND THE TARGET MONSTER OF ALL
TARGET MONSTERS FOR THE STEELERS
IN DIONTAE JOHNSON.
A FUN LIST WE GOT TODAY.
GREG, WHAT OTHER TREATS DO WE
HAVE IN STORE FOR THE PEOPLE?
>> I AM NOT ONLY GIVING OUT
HOODIES TODAY, CONNOR.
WE ARE NOT JUST GIVING AWAY
HOODIES.
I AM GIVING AWAY TWO NFL JERSEY
GIFT CARDS TODAY.
ONE GOES TO THE WINNING LOCK
LEGEND AND ONE GOES TO A LUCKY
COMMENTATOR LIKE YOU.
STAY TAPPED IN RIGHT HERE WITH
ME AND CONNOR.
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND DO WHAT
YOU DO.
IF YOU NEED A JERSEY, IF YOU
NEED A HOODIE, I NEED GIFS,
EMOJIS, BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I
NEED WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
SO THROW THOSE COMMENTS UP,
Y'ALL.
>> ALL RIGHT.
WE HAVE FOUR LEGENDARY PICKS TO
SHOW YOU.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL BY NOW.
THE WINNER TAKES HOME THE
JERSEY.
THE WINNER TAKES HOME THE TITLE
OF SQUAD RIDE LEADER.
GREG IS GOING TO WORK HIS MAGIC
AND BOOST THAT ANYTIME TOUCHDOWN
SCORE FOR DRAFTKINGS.
STICK AROUND.
OUR FIRST PITCH FROM JOSH STOTTS
28.
JOSH, TELL US WHO IS SCORING A
TOUCHDOWN TODAY.
>> WELCOME TO THE SPECIAL
HALLOWEEN B/R BETTING ANYTIME
TOUCHDOWN SCORE.
OUR SELECTIONS FOR THE DAY ARE
JA'MARR CHASE, DERRICK HENRY,
TYREEK HILL, COOPER KUPP, AND
JOSH ALLEN.
>> HELPING YOU MAKE MY PICK IS
MY LITTLE FRIEND WHO HOLDS THE
BOWL OF WISDOM.
I
I'M GOING TO CRUMBLE THESE
SELECTIONS UP A AND THE BOWL OF
WISDOM WILL DO THE REST.
AND THE PICK IS DERRICK HENRY.
>> SO THE BASEMENT OF SAW GOING
WITH DERRICK HENRY AT MINUS 165.
WE GOT THE FIRST CHALLENGE OF
THE DAY HERE.
THE FIRST DECISION THAT'S NOT
GOING TO BE UP TO ME, NOT UP TO
GREG, UP TO THE COMMENTS.
SO GET READY FOR THIS ONE.
HERE IS OUR SECOND PITCH FROM
MIKE OC.
♪
>> ALL RIGHT.
I'M ALREADY FREAKED OUT.
YOU HEARD THE FIRST TWO PITCHES.
WE GOT THE CLOWN LEGEND, THE
"STRANGER THINGS" VIBES GOING
ON, GREG.
DO YOU LIKE EITHER OF THESE
HERE?
>> CONNOR, BEFORE I GET IN HERE,
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS, TELL ME IF
YOU ARE RIDING WITH THE CLOWN
LEGEND UNDERER OR THE "STRANGER
THINGS" LEGEND.
I GIVE BOTH AN "A" FOR EFFORT.
BOTH "A" FOR EFFORT, VERY
CREATIVE.
SHOUT OUT TO THEM.
THEY ARE SPOOKY.
SHOUT OUT FOR TAKING THE --
PUTTING IN THE EFFORT,
BASICALLY.
BUT I NEED TO TALK ABOUT THESE
PICKS, CONNOR.
GOT TO TALK ABOUT THESE PICKS.
WE GOT DERRICK HENRY, JOSH
ALLEN.
LOVE THE DERRICK HENRY PLAY.
YOU THREW OUT A STAT THAT'S
SAYING WHEN HE DOESN'T SCORE, HE
USUALLY SCORES A GIVE MINUS 165.
I DON'T REALLY LIKE THAT.
I LIKE THIS JOSH ALLEN PLUS 100
BUS YO
BECAUSE WE CAN CHANGE THE PLUS
100, BOOST IT UP SOME MORE.
IT'S A GOOD BET.
EIGHTS FAIR BET.
I THINK I WANT TO LEAN JOSH
ALLEN.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I AM ROLLING WITH YOU.
I THINK BOTH YOU AND I FEEL
GREAT ABOUT DERRICK HENRY
GETTING IN THE END ZONE THIS
WEEK.
BUT AT WHAT COST?
WHAT MONEY IS THERE, RIGHT?
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE ODDS HERE.
JOSH ALLEN HAS THE DOLPHINS.
THEY ARE FAVORED BY TWO
TOUCHDOWNS.
WE KNOW WHAT JOSH ALLEN CAN DO
ON THE GROUND AS A RUNNER.
HE IS THEIR RED ZONE RUNNING
OFFENSIVE THREAT.
PLUS 100?
I WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU CAN BOOST
THAT UP TO.
I AM ROLLING WITH JOSH ALLEN.
HOW ARE THE COMMENTS FEELING
RIGHT NOW ABOUT BOTH OF THESE?
>> CONNOR, I AM IN THE COMMENTS
RIGHT NOW, AND EARLY, IT'S
EARLY, I'M SEEING A LOT OF
DERRICK HENRY.
SEEING A LOT OF DERRICK HENRY.
I GOT NOT JAYLEN WADDLE WITH THE
DERRICK HENRY GIF.
I WILL SHOW YOU GUYS.
THERE IT IS.
MY BOY DERRICK HENRY AT ALABAMA
WITH THE GIF.
I GOT MODISI, DERRICK HENRY TWO
TOUCHDOWNS, WINNERS ONLY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, MO DEEZY.
CONNOR, DO NOT BE AFRAID BECAUSE
JOSH ALLEN IS GETTING SOME LOVE,
TOO.
MONKS AND MISFITS SAYS JOSH
ALLEN.
ACTUALLY, WE ARE GOING TO CALL
IT WITH THIS NEXT ONE.
WE ARE GOING TO CALL IT WITH
THIS NEXT ONE.
I GOT T GIBSON SAYING JOSH
ALLEN.
SO, CONNOR, IT APPEARS THAT
PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
IT'S ACTUALLY BACK AND FORTH
FROM THE COMMENTS.
I AM GOING OFF THE LAST COMMENT
I JUST READ.
IT APPEARS, PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN,
WE ARE ROCKING WITH THE
"STRANGER THINGS" LEGEND AND
JOSH ALLEN TO MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
>> A TIGHT ROUND ONE.
THAT BELONGS TO MIKE OC.
WE GOT TWO SPOOKY CHALLENGERS
REMAINING.
ON TO ROUND TWO.
OUR NEXT PITCH COMES FROM STAGER
12.
WHO YOU GOT?
♪
>> JA'MARR CHASE.
I LOVE THAT PICK.
LOVE THE HALLOWEEN DECOR FROM
STAGER.
ALL RIGHT, THE HALLOWEEN PARTY
LEGEND.
TAKING ON THE "STRANGER THINGS."
GREG, THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
TIGHTER, BOTH PLUS MONEY, WE
LOVE THAT.
JA'MARR CHASE HAS THE JETS.
BIG-TIME BENGAL FAVORITES.
JOSH ALLEN HAS THE DOLPHINS,
BIG-TIME BILLS FAVORITES.
I THINK BOTH OF THESE GUYS MIGHT
SCORE TODAY.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> CONNOR, THIS IS TOUGH, MAN.
THIS IS TOUGH.
I'M GOING TO ASK THE PEOPLE.
YOU GUYS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
LET ME KNOW.
ARE WE ROCKING WITH THE, NOT THE
HOLD,
HOLLYWOOD, BUT NOT THE
"HALLOWEEN" PARTY LEGEND.
JA'MARR CHASE LIKES TO DANCE A
LITTLE BIT, YOU KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING?
ARE WE ROCKK WITH THE
"HALLOWEEN" PARTY LEGEND OR IS
IT THE "STRANGER THINGS" LEGEND?
GET IN THE COMMENTS.
CONNOR, I'M KEEPING THIS SIMPLE,
SHORT AND SWEET.
JA'MARR CHASE TAKING ON THOSE
NEW YORK JETS, THAT JETS
SECONDARY, WE KNOW HOW THAT GOES
FOR THE NEW YORK JETS.
BUT JA'MARR CHASE HAS BEEN
BAWLING, MAN.
HE IS HOT RIGHT NOW.
I'M GOING TO RIDE JA'MARR CHASE.
SITTING AT PLUS 110.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE, US HERE ON THE
DRAFTKINGS SPORTSBOOK SHOW,
WHICH IS CALLED "THE SQUAD
RIDE," YOU KNOW WHAT WE CAN DO.
WE BOOST THE ODDS FOR YOU GUYS.
SO I MIGHT WANT TO RIDE WITH
JA'MARR CHASE, CONNOR.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU THINKING?
>> I AM GOING WITH JA'MARR CHASE
AS WELL.
SPECIAL SEASON FOR JA'MARR.
THERE ARE WEEKS HE GETS IN THE
END ZONE TWICE.
THIS TO ME, JOE BURROW TO CHASE
IS THE NEW MATT RYAN TO JULIO.
I THINK HE IS SPECIAL.
I LIKE THE HALLOWEEN VIBES AS
WELL.
I'M ROLLING WITH JA'MARR CHASE.
CAN WE PUSH THE PEOPLE TO DO THE
SAME, GREG?
HOW ARE THEY FEELING?
>> LET ME ASK THEM.
I ALREADY ASKED THEM.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
YEP, WE PUSHED THEM, CONNOR.
IT'S A RUNAWAY.
CHASE, CHASE, CHASE.
I GOT BRANDON BROAD STRUM,
JA'MARR CHASE IS A LOCK, NO
DOUBT.
MATT DODGER GOING WITH JA'MARR
CHASE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, MATT DODGER.
JOSH GOATS, JA'MARR CHASE.
J.T. FOR MVP 0, CHASE IS A LOCK.
THAT'S FOUR HOODIES THAT I JUST
GAVE OUT.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED, YOU
ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
CONNOR, IT APPEARS, THE
"HALLOWEEN" PARTY LEGEND, I
DON'T KNOW WHY I KEEP CALL IT
HOLLYWOOD, I THINK JA'MARR CHASE
WILL HAVE A HOLLYWOOD DAY TODAY.
I THINK HE IS GOING TO PUT ON A
SHOW.
IT'S THE VIBES.
JA'MARR CHASE IS GOING TO PUT ON
A SHOW TODAY AND WE ARE ROCKING
WITH HIM, HE IS MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT ROUND.
LET'S GO.
>> THE FINAL ROUND.
SECOND ROUND BELONGS TO STAGER
12.
LIKE I SAID, THIS IS WINNER
TAKES ALL.
THIS IS THE TAKE HOME THE
JERSEY.
THIS IS TAKE HOME "THE SQUAD
RIDE" LEADER TITLE.
HALLOWEEN A LITTLE DIFFERENT, A
LITTLE EXTRA SPECIAL, A LITTLE
EXTRA SOMETHING.
NEXT UP, FAMILIAR FACE, RILEY
SORBO.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU GOT FOR US
TODAY, RILEY.
>> WHAT'S UP, SQUAD RIDE SQUAD
RIDE?
WE ARE OUT HERE TRYING TO MAKE
SOME PICKS.
WE ARE GOING TRICK-OR-TREATING,
SEE IF ANYONE HAS ANY IDEA WHO
MIGHT SCORE A TOUCHDOWN
TOMORROW.
LET'S SEE IF WE CAN FIGURE THIS
OUT.
OH, HI.
HEY, I AM OUT HERE
TRICK-OR-TREATING.
I KNOW IT'S A DAY EARLY.
YOU MAY NOT EVEN HAVE CANDY.
BUT I WAS WONDERING IF YOU MAY
HAVE AN IDEA WHO MIGHT SCORE A
TOUCHDOWN TOMORROW?
IN THE NFL.
>> KAMARA.
>> ALVIN KAMARA?
>> OKAY, YOU HEARD IT.
ALVIN KAMARA.
LOCK IT IN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
HAVE A GREAT DAY.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> NOW, THAT IS A BOLD MOVE.
TRICK-OR-TREATING A DAY EARLY
AND ASKING FOR THE LOCK OF THE
WEEK.
NO HESITATION THERE EITHER.
HE SAID KAMARA RIGHT AWAY.
THIS IS A GREAT FINALE HERE,
GREG.
I AM LOOKING AT THAT PLUS MONEY.
WHICH WAY ARE YOU FEELING HERE?
CHASE OR KAMARA?
>> HEY, GET IN THE COMMENTS.
WHAT I NEED EVERYBODY TO DO,
BECAUSE THIS IS HARD, CONNOR.
THIS IS TOUGH.
ALVIN KAMARA, YOU KNOW HE IS THE
ENGINE FOR THAT SAINTS OFFENSE.
JA'MARR CHASE HAS BEEN HOT.
HE HAS BEEN HOT.
SO GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET
ME KNOW WHO WE SHOULD RIDE WITH.
THE "HALLOWEEN" PARTY LEGEND OR
THE TRICK-OR-TREAT LEGEND?
CONNOR, LOVE THE TAKE BY MY GUY
REILLY, LOVE THE TAKE BY MY GUY
RILEY.
BUT JA'MARR CHASE IS PLUS 110.
ALVIN KAMARA IS MINUS 150.
WE CAN BOOST THE ODDS UP FROM
MINUS 150 BUT WE CAN BOOST THE
ODDS MORE FOR PLUS 110.
I AM LEANING JA'MARR CHASE, MAN.
AND TAKING ON THE JETS.
>> THIS IS THE NO-BRAINER FINALE
TO ME, GREG.
I AM DEMANDING THE COMMENTS TO
GO WITH JA'MARR CHASE.
THE BOOK IS OUT ON THE SAINTS.
EVERY OTHER TEAM KNOWS IT'S
ALVIN KAMARA ALL DAY.
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY TO TAKE
HIM AWAY.
EVERY SINGLE WEEK, WHOEVER IS
PLAYING THE SAINTS IS GOING TO
TRY TO TAKE AWAY ALVIN KAMARA.
BUT JA'MARR CHASE I THINK THE
JETS CAN BRACKET HIM FOR ALL IT
MATTERS AND IT'S NOT GOING TO
STOP HIM.
THERE IS IN STOPPING HIM.
LOOK AT THE ODDS HERE.
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE DECIDER
HERE.
I WANT TO SEE WHAT YOU CAN GET
THE JA'MARR CHASE ODDS UP TO.
DID WE PUSH THE PEOPLE FAR
ENOUGH?
IS THIS OVER?
>> IT MIGHT BE, CONNOR.
IT MIGHT BE.
THE COMMENTS ARE JUMPING.
I GOT ROB POWELL 15, CHASER,
CHASER, SHOUTS OUT TO YOU, ROB
POWELL 15.
I GOT IRVIN SANCHEZ SAYING
CHASEY, CHASEY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, IRVIN SANCHEZ.
BOTH YOU GUYS ARE WALKING
AWAY -- I GUESS THEY ARE MAKING
UP NICKNAMES FOR MY GUY JA'MARR
CHASE IN THE COMMENTS.
HERE WE GO.
CHASING GHOST TD, HE JUST
APPEARS IN THE END ZONE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU D BLAKE 13.
LOVE THE TAKE.
IT'S A RUNAWAY, CONNOR.
D BUTLER 5 SAYS CHASE FOR
PRESIDENT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU D BUTLER 5.
MIGHT BE FOR PRESIDENT.
ONE MORE.
LEE ROSS GARZA SAYS CHASE HAS
THREE TOUCHDOWNS TODAY AGAINST
THE JETS, CONNOR.
WOO.
>> THAT'S A BONUS BET.
>> THAT WILL BE A DAY IF HE DOES
THAT.
SO, CONNOR, I THINK IT'S VERY
APPARENT, I THINK IT IS VERY
APPARENT THAT THE PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN.
WE ARE RIDING WITH THE HALLOWEEN
PARTY LEGEND AND STAGER 12 AND
JA'MARR CHASE AS "THE SQUAD
RIDE" OF THIS WEEK.
LET'S PULL UP THE GRAPHIC SO I
CAN SHOW YOU HOW WE ARE GOING TO
BOOST THOSE ODDS FOR YOU GUYS.
LOOK AT THIS MAGIC.
JA'MARR CHASE PLUS 110.
POOF.
THERE IT GOES.
IT WENT UP.
>> BIG TIME.
BIG TIME.
>> IT WENT UP FROM 110 TO 175.
SHOUT OUT TO OUR FRIENDS OVER AT
DRAFTKINGS.
THEY ARE BOOSTING THESE ODDS FOR
US OF THE CHECK OUT B/R BETTING
SOCIAL FOR A LINKS TO THE ODDS
BOOST.
SEND SCREEN SHOTS OF YOUR BETS.
SEND US YOUR VIDEOS AND YOUR
CELEBRATION.
BUT REMEMBER PLEASE REMEMBER WE
WANT WINNERS AND WINNERS ONLY,
PLEASE, CONNOR.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
GOT MORE LOCKS TO TALK.
YOU GOT HOODIES TO GIVE AWAY.
ONE MORE JERSEY TO GIVE AWAY IN
THE SPIRIT OF HALLOWEEN.
AND THE B/R BETTING COMMUNITY
STREAM IN THE B/R APP, WE ASKED
YOU IN THE SPIRIT OF THE
HOLIDAY, A LITTLE QUESTION IN
THE COMMENTS THERE FOR SCARY
TERRY.
HOW MANY RECEIVING YARDS FOR
SCARY TERRY AGAINST THE BRONCOS
THIS WEEK?
WE PICKED TO OF OUR FAVORITES
COMMENTS.
LET'S WASTE NO TIME, GREG.
LET'S LOOK HOW THE PEOPLE FEEL
ABOUT SCARY TERRY THIS WEEK.
>> YES, SIR, CONNOR.
WHAT I NEED THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WATCHING -- WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS
TO DO IS GET IN THE COMMENTS AND
TELL ME WHICH OF THESE IS THE
BETTER TAKE.
I AM GOING TO GIVE A HOODIE TO
WHOEVER YOU GUYS CHOOSE.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
FIRST COMMENT FROM KING GREEZY.
KING GLEEZZY SAYS 131 YARDS FOR
KARY TERRY WITH A COUPLE OF
MOE
EMOJIS AT THE END, CONNOR.
HOW ARE YOU FEELING ABOUT THIS
TAKE?
131 FOR SCARY TERRY?
>> I THINK WE FOUND SCARY
TERRY'S BIGGEST FAN.
THE LINE AT 67 1/2 RECEIVING
YARDS.
THIS MAN DUCKED THAT OUT OF THE
GATE.
THIS IS A LITTLE RICH FOR ME,
GREG.
I AM GOING TO BE HONEST.
IT'S NOT SCARY TERRY'S FAULT.
THEY GOT CORNERS.
HIS QUARTERBACK SITUATION HAS
JUST NOT BEEN WHAT WE EXPECTED,
OF COURSE, SINCE RYAN
FITZPATRICK GOT HURT.
IS THE NEXT COMMENT GOING TO BE
A LITTLE MORE PESSIMISTIC OR ARE
WE ROLLING THE GOOD SCARY TERRY
VIBES HERE?
>> LET'S SEE.
THE NEXT COMMENT IS FROM KMIZ
123.
AND CONNOR, KMIZ SAYS SEVEN FOR
127.
AND A TD ALL IN THE LOSING
EFFORT.
WOW, THAT IS BIG.
ALL RIGHT.
CONNOR, THE FIRST ONE SAID 131
YARDS.
NOW WE'RE TALKING 127.
DID THAT CHANGE YOUR MIND A
LITTLE BIT?
>> MAN --
>> GET TO 127?
>> I'M CONSIDERING THE OVER AT
67 1/2.
I DIDN'T SAY DOUBLE IT OUT HERE.
THIS IS CRAZY.
I THINK THEY LIKE THE SAME GAME
PARLAY OPTION WHERE YOU CAN
REALLY BUMP UP THE TOTALS FOR
EACH PLAYER.
THESE ARE BOTH NUTS TO ME, GREG,
AND I RESPECT IT AND I HOPE THEY
ARE RIGHT AND I HOPE WE LOOK
FOOLISH.
THE PEOPLE AGREE.
IS THIS JUST A SCARY TERRY FAN
BASE TODAY?
>> HEY, SHOUT OUT TO MODISI.
HE SAYS SCARY TERRY OVER 67 1/2.
HE IS PUTTING THEM TO A SLEEP.
THAT'S A LOT.
HEY, ANYTHING'S POSSIBLE THOUGH.
YOU KNOW, ANYTHING IS POSSIBLE.
GREAT, GREAT, GREAT PLAYER.
I GOT JOE TEACH 27 SAYS SIX
RECEPTIONS, 57 YARDS AND A TD
FOR SCARY TERRY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU JOE TEACH.
HERE WE GO.
TERRY ABOUT TO GO OFF.
D BOY 22 SAYS TERRY IS ABOUT TO
GO OFF.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED, YOU
GUYS ARE WALKING AWAY WITH THE
HOODIE.
ALSO KING GREEZY IS WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE BECAUSE I JUST
WANTED TO PICK HIM.
WHY NOT?
I LIKE YOUR TAKE BETTER.
131.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SO WE GO FROM LAUGHING AT
COMMENTS.
NOW PEOPLE CAN LAUGH AT US
BECAUSE IT'S BOLDEST BETS OF THE
WEEK TIME.
THIS IS WHY WE GET CRAZY,
SPRINKLE SOME MONEY ON BIG-TIME
LONG SHOTS.
GREG, TELL THE PEOPLE WHAT WE
NEED FOR THE BOLDEST BETS TIME.
>> CONNOR, WHAT I NEED THE
PEOPLE TO DO IS GET IN THE
COMMENTS AND TELL ME IF THEY ARE
RIDING WITH ME OR RIDING WITH
YOU.
YEAH, YOU GUYS JUST LET US KNOW.
CONNOR'S BEEN HOT.
HE HAS HIT A COUPLE OF THESE
BEFORE.
LET US KNOW IF YOU ARE RIDING
WITH ME, RIDING WITH CONNOR.
CONNOR, TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
WHO DO YOU GOT?
>> I AM LOOKING AT YOUR NINERS.
LOOKING FOR THE JUICE TO GET IN
THE END ZONE.
KYLE USYUS CHECK, ONLY ONE
TOUCHDOWN.
ONE TOUCHDOWN FOR THE JUICE TO
GET LOOSE AT PLUS 450.
FEELING OKAY ABOUT THIS.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO PUT UP
A LOT OF POINTS AGAINST THE
BEARS WITHOUT KHALIL MACK.
I LOVE YOUR PICK.
LOVE THE CHECKDOWN TO THE
RUNNING BACKS IAND THE FULLBACK.
YOU HAVE A GOOD PICK THERE,
CONNOR.
LET ME HOP IN HERE.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING JA'MARR
CHASE ALL DAY, IT SEEMS LIKE.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
JA'MARR CHASE.
PULL UP THE GRAPHIC SO I CAN
SHOW THE PEOPLE.
THERE IT IS.
JA'MARR CHASE TO GET 150 PLUS
RECEIVING YARDS AND A TOUCHDOWN
AGAINST THOSE NEW YORK JETS.
>> HE CAN DO IT.
>> I LIKE -- I LIKE MY CHANCES
HERE.
HE HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY HOT THIS
SEASON.
HE HAS A CONNECTION WITH JOE
BURROW.
SO I CAN SEE THIS HAPPENING.
LOOK AT THE ODDS.
PLUS 600, BRO.
I'M ROLLING THE DICE, CONNOR.
>> I LOVE THOSE ODDS.
THIS IS A FUN ONE.
WE ARE ON JA'MARR CHASE TODAY
FOR HALLOWEEN.
I LOVE THAT ONE.
WE HAVE TO LET THE PEOPLE DECIDE
WHO THEY ARE RIDING WITH.
I KNOW YOU STILL HAVE A JERSEY
TO GIVE AWAY BEFORE WE GET OUT
OF HERE TODAY.
>> YES, YES, YES, SIR, YES, SIR.
LET ME GET INTO THE COMMENTS.
LET ME GET INTO THESE COMMENTS.
HERE WE GO.
LET ME GET INTO THESE COMMENTS,
MAN.
THEY ARE MOVING.
RIDING WITH CONNOR ALL DAY.
JOSH GOATS.
>> RESPECT.
>> SHOUT OUT TO JOSH GOATS.
AK-47 BIG BLUE SAYS BOTH OF YOU
GOT GOOD PICKS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU AK-47, LOVING
THE VIBES.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
CONNOR, DID YOU SAY SOMETHING
ABOUT A JERSEY?
>> SOMETHING ABOUT A JERSEY,
MAN.
YOU STILL GOT ONE MORE JERSEY.
IT'S HALLOWEEN.
YOU WANT TO STOP AT GREG'S
PLACE.
NO CANDY.
NO COCONUT CANDY.
YOU ARE GETTING THE GOOD STUFF.
>> LET ME HOP IN HERE.
LET ME HOP IN HERE.
CONNOR, YOU ARE GETTING LOVE IN
THE COMMENTS.
YOU ARE GETTING LOVE.
I GOT GO WHITE SOX.
GO WHITE SOX SAYS CONNOR DOESN'T
MISS.
LET'S GET IT, BABY.
CONNOR DOESN'T MISS.
GUESS WHAT, GO WHITE SOX?
YOU DIDN'T MISS ON THIS JERSEY.
>> THERE WE GO.
>> WALKING AWAY WITH THE JERSEY
FOR THE LOVE YOU SHOWED TO MY
GUY CONNOR.
CONNOR ROGERS AT THAT.
>> GOOD VIBES ON THE HALLOWEEN
SHOW TODAY.
I THINK EVERYBODY IS IN A
REALLY, REALLY GOOD MOOD FOR
SOME WINNERS TODAY.
BEFORE WE GOT OUT OF HERE SWE
GOT SOMETHING SPECIAL.
THE TRICK-OR-TREAT SPECIAL FOR
DRAFTKINGS.
OUR FRIENDS HOOKING US UP WITH A
SPECIAL HALLOWEEN ODDS BOOST
MANIA.
JA'MARR CHASE TOUCHDOWN, GET THE
WAGERS IN.
LONG SHOTS, GET THE WAGERS IN.
SCARY TERRY CRAZINESS, HAVE FUN.
TRICK-OR-TREAT BETTING SPECIAL.
OPT IN AND YOU GET ONE OF TWO
FUTURES BOOSTED.
READY, GREG?
THE TREAT FUTURE, CARDINALS,
RAVENS, PACKERS, CHARGERS, TIGHT
ENDS, CHIEFS TO MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS.
ALL OF THEM.
THEY GOT TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS.
ALL RIGHT?
NOW, THE TRICK FUTURE GIANTS,
DOLPHINS, JAGS, TEXANS, JETS OR
LIONS, YOU JUST NEED ONE OF THEM
TO MAKE THE PLAYOFFS.
NOT A GOOD POOL OF TEAMS.
SORRY.
WHICHEVER ONE IS RANDOMLY
SELECTED YOU GET BOOSTED PLUS
100.
I DREW THE TRICK OPTION.
NOT THRILLED ABOUT IT.
WOULD YOU BET ON IT?
DO YOU THINK ANY OF THOSE SORRY
TEAMS MAKE THE PLAYOFFS?
>> CONNOR, I AM NOT TOUCHING
THOSE SORRY TEAMS.
I'M LEAVING THAT -- I AM
LEAVING -- NO, NO, I'M LEAVING
THAT WHERE IT IS.
AND I MIGHT TOUCH THE TREAT
OPTION.
I MIGHT TOUCH THE TREAT WITH ALL
OF THE TEAMS TO MAKE THE
PLAYOFFS.
ONLY ONE I'M KIND OF SKEPTICAL
ABOUT IS THE LOS ANGELES
CHARGERS.
BUT THOSE OTHER TEAMS SHOULD
MAKE THE PLAYOFFS.
>> GET ON DRAFTKINGS AND SEE IF
YOU GET A TRICK OR A TREAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU DEFINITELY
WANT THAT TREAT.
LET US KNOW ON SOCIAL IF YOU ARE
RIDING WITH ANY OF THOSE.
HAPPY HALLOWEEN, EVERYONE.
GOOD LUCK WITH YOUR WAGERS
TODAY.
IT'S BEEN A LOT OF FUN.
IT'S ALWAYS A LOT OF FUN.
THESE HALLOWEEN THEMES ARE THE
GUEST.
CONGRATS TO THE HOODIE AND
JERSEY WINNERS.
B/R BETTING WILL DM YOU IN THE
NEXT 48 HOURS.
HAVE NO FEAR.
THANKS TO EVERYONE THAT
COMMENTED.
A LOT OF LOVE.
APPRECIATE THAT.
THANKS TO THE LOCK LEGENDS, JOSH
STOTTS, MIKE OC, REILLY, GREAT
VIDEOS BRINGING THAT HALLOWEEN
SPIRIT.
ENJOY YOUR SUNDAY.
>> WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
>> HE IS NOT DONE YET.
>> I'M SO SORRY.
>> RING THE DOORBELL.
>> I HAVE TO GIVE THE PEOPLE --
I HAVE TO GIVE THE PEOPLE WHAT
THEY WANT.
HERE WE GO.
I GOT LEE LAROSE GARZA SAYS
LOCK.
HE SAYS LOCK JUST FOR SAYING
LOCK, BROTHER, YOU GETTING A
HOODIE.
HERE WE GO.
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
D BLAKE 13 SAYS, OH CHASE NC.
SHOUT OUT D BLAKE.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
GOT ONE MORE IN ME, CONNOR.
GOAT GARDNER SAYS HAPPY
HALLOWEEN.
HAPPY HALLOWEEN, EVERYBODY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
>> FOLLOW B/R BETTING ALL DAY.
GREG IS HOLDING IT DOWN WITH THE
GOOD STUFF.
I AM CONNOR ROGERS.
SEE YOU NEXT WEEK.
SAME TIME, SAME PLACE.
♪